hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Samantha Ashley fell today we're gonna
check out from all-time movies top 5
movies with the most [ __ ] explicit
version Samantha she loves that word
[ __ ] trust me guys I don't know why you
say the word [ __ ] it activates the
button yeah and then I have a Taser in
case she that gets out of control
hi I'm Chris from all-time movies and
today I'm dipping into dad's cupboard of
naughty stuff to count down the most
foul-mouthed movies ever
Colleen know kind she retired [ __ ] off
you're revolting
look at your [ __ ] son turn like lever
not a lever man your skin you make a
[ __ ] suitcase out of you old door
knock crocodile fat crocodile fat
bastard I [ __ ] eat the oven yeah I
mean oh I'm [ __ ] G so to keep things
simple we're just counting the [ __ ] I'm
on the [ __ ] number [ __ ] I mean
five alpha dog really can you believe
that [ __ ] after everything I've done for
that [ __ ]
look Johnny [ __ ] him let's get the hell
out of Dodge go to Fiesta [ __ ]
alpha dog has about three hundred and
sixty-seven F bombs or about Wow a
minute [ __ ] deadbeat man go and get
the [ __ ] outta here the story about drug
dealers in California was the launch pad
for loads of young stars including
Amanda Seyfried Amber Heard and
[ __ ] Chekhov but it's mostly
remembered for starring Justin
Timberlake and Olivia Wilde's
considerable assets something wrong ya
know it's not even hard number four
Kasim I can see that I want to talk the
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] nice come don't
[ __ ] up in here Martin Scorsese loves
making epic gangster movies and there
are loads of room for swearing in this
3r mob movie
setting you guessed it a casino of all
places when I don't see any [ __ ]
elephant's okay we're going to Europe
let the adults talk I cast around 422 F
words but most of that's just
[ __ ] Joe Pesci what a [ __ ]
game
genrih prick you know that's what you
are I gave you money to pay the [ __ ]
rent and buy groceries put the heat on
you know your wife girlfriend he told me
the [ __ ] Heat's off
okay and you didn't gamble on [ __ ]
money and you stand here and tell me
that no no don't [ __ ] with me out don't
make a [ __ ] out of me
number three know by mouth
back in the 90s Gary Oldman those either
shouting loudly in grey movies or
directing actors to shark lobby in great
movies this semi-autobiographical drama
is the button abusive husband which
means about 428 F words in two hours
not to mention 82 [ __ ] or C words
there's a lot of [ __ ] yeah number two
dancer summer of Sam what is it with the
[ __ ] 90s wearing spiky joints don't
come sweary than this though it's a
pretty good drama about the Son of Sam
killings in 1977 any movie with a
talking psycho dog is worth your [ __ ]
time good number [ __ ] Jerry of Wall
Street this is our golden ticket to the
[ __ ] Chocolate Factory right
again ever
that's five hundreds and a whole lot of
bitching it's all pretty creative you
have to admit one day though when you
finally wins that Oscar I really hope he
gives his acceptance speech in the style
of Jordan Belfort okay so those are my
five most foul-mouthed movies ever
what's your favorite [ __ ] movie
insult let me know in the [ __ ]
comments below and if you like this
[ __ ] video check out the five biggest
movie robots now they're not as
offensive as this list but they'll just
[ __ ] kill you
Wow Wow okay it's been a while since
I've heard the [ __ ] word so many times
normally I just use it you know when I'm
like I'm actually doing it you know
really yeah I'm gonna wait to use it in
real life who are you not a fan of that
word I think it's a disgusting word
contact you get on board with [ __ ] mmm
that's just too offensive
really yeah I mean [ __ ] is just a vagina
but [ __ ] is like involving two people
it's like if you see [ __ ] you like
someone says [ __ ] you to me I'm like
this person wants to [ __ ] me
they wanna what what if it's somebody
that you would want no nothin break for
you so we're dramatic jeez drama King
over here so if a girl said [ __ ] you to
me but it was someone I want blood if
it's in a fit of anger it's not gonna be
beautiful passionate love I want it to
be like angelic I don't want it to be
like you know like let's just [ __ ]
unless she's a [ __ ] for a [ __ ] I don't
know what to do with you right now no I
use the [ __ ] word all the time
I have a business that wasn't expecting
alpha dog to be on this list I was
making alpha dog either I don't realize
that so many f-bomb did it no JT was
such a potty mouth huh oh he needs a
clean mouth out with soap yeah he does
he really does and Jessica Biel's
boobies - he's he still with her yeah he
has they have a kid what yeah he must be
so hot
how's the kid no okay no not even that
too soon
I actually liked alpha dog and you know
it's what's cool about this list of five
movies is these movies are not terrible
films you know it'd be one thing if
these were just horrible movies that had
a lot of sweary they were just like you
know really degrading kind of films but
a lot of these films are not like the
worst movies ever alpha dogs call I mean
you see Olivia Wilde's boobies weight
full-on I'm pretty if my memory serves
me correctly in that scene when she's
trying to get a meal her shard you see
her boobies
well guys go check it out and let us
know if we're correct you and Olivia
Wilde kind of have the similar eyes
actually I know they're kind of like big
you got big eyes like the movie big eyes
tim burton I don't have big eyes
director of Batman Returns anyhoo wait
so have you been told that before I love
you well no big eyes
no you've never been told that no we're
not like big eyes you have like eyes
that you know like my eyes always look
like half closed no your eyes are like
you know why to open without your
eyebrows going up here like yeah yeah
that's a casino
you know Scorsese his films tend to have
a lot of swear words in it yeah it is
one of his buddy they know Huguenots
Hugo Joe Pesci and Joe Pesci and De Niro
you know cuz deers always he's always
[ __ ] swearing yeah yeah
Tom Sabo [ __ ] bet show that's pretty
good Joe Pesci is always like hey you
think I'm a [ __ ] clown huh
be my [ __ ] clown shut up Samantha I'm
trying I'm just being honest yeah I'm
trying who's being I mean honest - and
then you got offended by it
I did not see nil by mouth but I want to
see it cuz Ray Winstone is
Arvid ray winstone scary [ __ ] guy in
general now he's playing an abusive
father in that film that looks like it
would be an interesting film to watch
because Ray Winstone is already
terrifying so knowing that he is an
abusive father would make him even more
terrifying plus he uses the word [ __ ] a
lot so I feel like it's that kind of
thing where yeah he's a dick but I could
hang out with this guy because the word
[ __ ] is a good work my girlfriend loves
that word absolutely baby it's true how
do you feel about the con word she hates
it why do you hate that word you know
you like it no my girlfriend's a liar
she calls me that all the time in bed
you like being called oh yeah she's like
give me your [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] but
wolf of wallstreet that was a very that
was the one I got right Scarface isn't
on this list but wolf of Wall Street is
it totally vulgar [ __ ] film and it's
great it's a great film though high
energy that's what I mean it's like I
don't care if there's a lot of swearing
in it as long as the film is justified
well and it's wearing yeah and there's a
reason for it like it makes sense that
wolf of Wall Street had so many f-bombs
and everything else that they listed it
was necessary for what they were
demonstrating it like they weren't
throwing it away per se it had to do
with the environment and it's part of
the characters language you know and
that's what I can feel from even
snippets of the films that I I don't
really remember that well I saw Casino
twice but I don't remember it fully
I know these directors tend to like to
let their actors improvise and naturally
in a part of our language swear words
come out so it makes sense that there
will be more swear words and films where
they allow their actors to actually
improvise especially that's you know
that's a part of the character that's
part of the life yeah I think it makes
it more real as long as there's you know
you're not having some I don't know
schoolgirl randomly dropping a bunch of
f-bombs oh yeah Sara Lee makes sense
yeah that's true it makes sense for
these feel you know wolf of wallstreet
make sense
you know make sense I like this [ __ ]
video I like this [ __ ] channel
all-time movies yeah you guys gotta go
subscribe to them it's a good [ __ ]
Channel
yeah [ __ ] yeah I would [ __ ] this [ __ ]
channel no too far that's not too far
told you I might be in too deep if you
know what I mean
anyway guys if we do the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out some mathas channel over here
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope and let's do
a shout out to a [ __ ]
Isaac [ __ ] Rodriguez hey [ __ ] Ryan
my name is [ __ ] Isaac I'm a fan of
the real [ __ ] rejects watch your
[ __ ] videos every [ __ ] day keep up
the good [ __ ] work
Isaac Rodriguez there's not that many
[ __ ] in there there's not as many folks
as I was trying to to make it sound like
a more interesting type of shout-out
request Isaac is a character in the
Bible though if I'm not mistaken he is
the one who parted the Red Sea no died
for us so we could go to heaven
no no ate the apple know that what that
was Adam the next Isaac then cool dude
Isaac dude yeah you might be a cool dude
but seriously man need a better name
okay if you're gonna go with a Bible
name go with like can't think of no no
and the only Bible I read was the
children's comic book Bible yes oh don't
listen on Isaac you're cool
Isaac Rodriguez has a little ring to it
you're a football player
oh no that you want to tackle me and
call me a [ __ ] huh do you want him to
maybe Veronica I think your boyfriend
has something he needs to tell you he
wants to be tackled by a man just Isaac
though you'd like Isaac alright just as
one